well good morning everyone and can i
welcome everyone to
development control committee a um
can i just first we'll run through some
of the domestic arrangements please
can you please ensure that you maintain
social distancing from other persons in
the chamber
and in the social areas please ensure
that you wear a mask unless you're
speaking
or if you're not sorry or if you're
unable to do so
that you use the hand sanitizers and
wipes provided
please maintain social distancing at all
times during the meetings and any breaks
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you're not speaking
please do not interrupt other speakers
members are reminded they should not
have alternative communication lines
open ie teams chats and if you are
contacted by a third party during an
application
before us please bring it to the
attention of the legal advisor
if please note that if you are attending
the meeting to speak please do not
interrupt the meeting
or you may be asked to leave
additionally you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by myself as chair of
the meeting
and we'll be using e-voting for this
meeting on modern.gov
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting is being broadcast live to the
internet
and will be capable of repute repeated
viewings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
this meeting you'll be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council's
member of the public and the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
so welcome everyone i've just run
through um some of the people that are
here with us today
so we have ian de prez who's our legal
advisor
we have philip isbell the chief planning
officer and john patemanji the area
planning manager
robert carmichael the governance officer
daniel cameron and badly heifer who are
presenting
we have uh in charge of i.t mandy and
the team
uh and i sorry i don't know who's joined
you mandy
alicia welcome uh and then we have the
ward members
uh today for today's applications will
be councillor helen geek counselor sarah
manson counselor
andrew mellon so i think that covers it
all
okay so we'll move straight into a
gender item number one
uh apologies for absence and
substitutions do we have any please
thank you cheer we have apologies this
morning from councillor richard mayer
councillor rachel ebern and councillor
tim passmore and we have substitutions
of councillor james carson for
councillor mayer councillor roland
warboys for councillor ebern
and counselor susie morley for
councillor tim parcell
thanks very much okay agenda item number
two is to receive declarations of
pecuniary or non-pecuniary interest by
members do we have any to declare
none received thank you gender item 3 is
declarations of lobbying
certainly on the second application
before us today i've received multiple
emails
as have all the members apart from those
that are substituting
okay thank you um
declarations of personal site visits did
anyone need to declare a personal site
visit
an unreceived thank you agenda item
number five is a confirmation the
minutes of the meeting that were held on
the 12th of may
2021 is before you
um i'll just run through those by page
if you've got anything just put your
hand up page one
page two page three
page four five and six are we happy that
i signed those as a true record of the
meeting is that agreed
agreed yeah
oh sorry of course electronic we need to
vote electronically
okay over to you robert
signed in because i haven't got one i've
got one person short on the voting
system
it's councillor mata and i have got you
logged in now so that's fantastic but
counselor i'll just double check
that's all boys yeah it's on the system
right if i had you in you should have
been
um added in right i'll sort out very
quickly now chair
so that counselor or voice is on there
and then we will be able to go to the
electronic vote
apologies for that counselor
right if you could try logging in again
counselor that should now
and then go to the attendance of voting
that should now show you
you should now be able to login on there
i can't start a chair until we're all
logged in i'm afraid
apologies for that counselor boys cheer
so i'll now start the vote
for the minutes of the last meeting so
if members
could go to the plus on the top right
hand corner and go to the attendance and
slash voting tab
and um the vote will show a subsection
and will appear then in blue let's now
in progress
[Music]
yeah sorry chair that's apologies on my
throat
i just have a proposal
right we have just one vote remaining to
castle molly do you want to cast your
vote verbally
brilliant thank you chair all votes has
now been received and that's five votes
for
zero against and three abstentions thank
you lovely thank you very much
okay um agenda item number six is
receive notification petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme have you received any
non-received chair okay so we'll move
straight on to the schedule of planning
applications
excuse me uh first item is agenda item
7a dc
2102564 land south of old stone market
road
wool pit and now invite the case officer
bradley heifer to introduce the
application to the committee
bradley over to you
thank you chair uh good morning members
this application the first on the agenda
today is
a reserve matters proposal which is
seeking approval for a car park
to serve the health center at woolpit
this plan is a wider aerial view of the
location
the actual area that you're seeing
hatched there
relates to the outline planning
permission that was granted
for residential development and the car
park
under the application in 2016
and for orientation obviously there's a
settlement a wall pit here
elmswell and tostock
this is a larger scale plan which again
shown the overall plan
for the outline but it's important to
note the
the constraints that are shown on there
which include the built up
area boundary which is shown brown
the constellation area for wool pit
which is shown in the lilac colour
and the cluster of listed buildings
which are towards the center of the
settlement
and a single listed building to the
right-hand side of the site as you look
at it
this is the site itself for the car park
and this is useful in order to gauge
its location in relation to existing
residential development
which is in saffron's close and there is
the wool pit health center which this
car park
would serve
that's a plan of the car park as part of
the outline planning permission i
mentioned
there's a condition that says there's
got to be 136
spaces in the car park this
accords with that requirement as well as
that overall number
it's proposed that there would be cycle
parking
located in this corner and also some
spaces
for power to two wheelers in other words
motorbikes motorcycles
you can also just about see hopefully
that
area of parking along here which is
allocated
for disabled users disabled motorists
um and the other thing to point out on
here well that's very faint
unfortunately
is the line or sorry is the
illumination around the edge of the car
park
because obviously it's got to be
illuminated and there's a single column
in the middle
this plan shows the soft landscaping
proposals and as you can see from that
it's not proposed to take out any of the
trees
or hedging along the boundary with the
properties in saffron close
nor is it proposed to impact on the the
nice tree which is located
away with outside the site um to the
southeast
um what you can see in effect is the
softening of the boundary so you've got
a combination of planting
grassed areas and areas around here
which is shown as hedging
to soften the overall impact
hard landscaping proposals i've included
this because this shows links through
because although this is allocated sorry
this is linkedin with the outline
planning permission that was granted
for the residential development you can
see ghosted on the sides here
in anticipation of links through
particularly to development that's
going to come on stream to the south
which i think came to committee recently
for your consideration
you'll see that there's links through
for
cycles and pedestrians to access through
there
the other thing that's useful to point
out on this slide
is that the main access to this car park
is to take place from this point through
the residential area
um but as i've said in the report the
means of access won't be available in
time
because of the covert issues um we're
keen to
to get the um the car park provided
asap so therefore that requires an
emergency form of access
through from the um health centre
um white line signing plan basically
that's been included so you can see that
the the general maneuver of vehicles
around the site
and also you'll note that on the on the
ground there's a five mile an hour
speed limit this plan is useful because
it shows i mentioned the the lighting
earlier
this is the shared boundary edged red
sorry
lined red with the properties in saffron
close
these lines here show the illumination
that leads on from the lighting columns
which are shown
as the red dots and as you'll note that
lighting columns that are nearest the
residential unit
residential development for example they
will obviously face towards a car park
so the illumination is controlled at
that point so there's no backwash
illumination which is an important point
so therefore while there will be you
know obviously there'll be
residents will note there's a car park
there the actual level illumination has
been
controlled so that it wouldn't be an
adverse impact
these are the barrier details it's
proposed to install at the
northern entrance and also at the uh
temporary access that's been proposed
that in effect is a gate i'm sure
everyone's seen
this sort of thing before in car parks
and in the case of the northern uh
entrance
it's proposed there'll be a height
restrictor as well
um i'll finish with some views um as
i've said in the report
the means of access through from
wallpaper health center
means that some hedging had to be lost
in order to affect that um and that had
to be done
prior obviously to the nesting season so
as you can see that's
that's been carried out into
anticipation of the work
you can also see in the distance there
the construction of the houses
um on the adjacent site so therefore
that the area we're looking at
is the fenced area to the foreground
it's the flat grassed area
and that's the tree i was talking about
the nice tree that would be unimpacted
by this
proposal um and that's the area to the
south
which linked through to the car park
which
as i say recently i think gained outline
planning permission
for residential development
i've included these uh doors sorry these
photographs just give you an idea of
the stage of the work that's on the
remainder of the site this is taken
behind the hedgerow
which faces onto old stone market road
and you can see the developers are
um are getting on with the um the
residential development
and the properties you can just see
in the distance there are the edges
sorry
the rears of properties in saffron close
lastly i'd like to draw your attention
to the table
papers which hopefully you've had a
chance to look at
as i've said in the uh my report because
of the urgency
behind the application and the need to
get it
basically up and running as quickly as
we can
we had to get this to committee um it's
an application made on behalf of the
council that's why it's come to you
but we had to get it quickly and um the
public
sorry the publicity period hadn't
expired uh when the
uh application report was produced
so following on from the production of
the report
on the table papers you can see that
we've had comments now
from woolpit parish council they've been
put in
verbatim and we've also had a comment
through from the highway authority um
they haven't
raised an issue with the um with the
proposal in terms of highway safety
because obviously the traffic generation
arising from the car park
would have been included as part of the
overall residential development
at the time of the outline that would
have been factored in so there is no
issue with that
um i have checked i checked yesterday
and the although the access wouldn't be
available to the north
for people to actually use the car park
it is intended to use the northern
access
or an access from the north for
construction vehicles
to actually construct the car park so
there wouldn't be a situation
where um construction vehicles are
driving through warfight
wall pit health center car park which
obviously could create some sort of
conflicts
so i'll just say that the other thing i
would point out is that if you were
minded to accept the recommendation
we think it's important um to add a
condition saying that
the temporary means of access from
the health center is only in emergency
access
make that absolutely clear so you know a
condition would
be imposed it that makes it clear that
you wouldn't be
um um sorry would give granting
permanent permission for that to be used
as a vehicular access
the final con uh comment on the
um table papers relates to ecology and
as you can see
um they've got no objection um
they've asked for the imposition of a
construction environmental
management plan but that was imposed as
part of the outline planning
approval so it's not necessary to
reimpose the same condition on the
reserve matters
the other thing that's not on there that
we have received we got that yesterday
was a response from our
landscaping consultants and they haven't
raised the rejections to the proposal
what they've asked for is adjustments in
the mix
of planting um to better reflect
what they feel is a more appropriate mix
of that location
so again we've got an outlet as part of
the outline planning permission
we've got a condition which requires the
submission of a landscaping scheme
so we feel that that can be dealt with
in that
particular way
i think that's picked up all the points
i wanted to say now
the only thing i think is pertinent to
point out now is that the
the advert period or the notification
period on this doesn't expire to the 9th
of june
so if you're reminded to recommend or
accept the recommendation
we would still have until the 9th of
june to see whether any material
comments were made that would you know
require that this to be brought back to
planning committee anyway so there is
that
that issue as well but that's all i need
to say at this day thank you
thank you thank you very much and do we
have any questions at all
yes counselor casting first
thank you very much and thank you for
the presentation i
just in terms of drainage i haven't
quite got to grips
with how the site's drained i've got um
slide
six in our papers um has got the filter
drain on there but i can't actually
see it on the um on the plan
yes thank you councillor the idea is
that the channels between the spaces
would be drainage reels in other words
so you'd actually get drainage heading
northwards which is counterintuitive
because you always
imagine everything drops down but in the
way that the land works um
it drops up so the the actual drainage
would be the reels through here
um linking through with the the surface
treatment
generally which would form towards that
and then you've got
some collection points there and there
which lead to a storage attenuation
crate
system under the ground and then
following on from that
that then leads through to the drainage
that's being laid to serve the
residential it's like
as i said in the report it's only um
surface water provision anyway clearly
because it's uh
it's a car parts there's no foul in this
particular one
so yeah yeah thank you for that so
there's a crate system in there
so yeah it's it's all solved them in
terms of the
lighting do we have any um
rules on conditions on when the light
when the lighting comes on when the
lighting goes off and um
do we have any conditions on the um the
type of
lights that are used energy wise or you
know
in terms of the types of lighting
there's a condition that was put on the
outline
which requires details to be approved of
lighting
so we've got that control in place and
as i say that's site-wide that includes
a residential but
it bites on the the um the car park as
well
so we've got that control with regard to
hours of operation of lighting things
like that
that's um incorporated into the
management plan which i've touched on in
the report
that isn't an issue to be considered at
this stage because the management plan
is yet another a condition attached to
the outline so that would have to be
agreed as a separate issue
but the the operation and hours and
things like that and
those sorts of things will be
incorporated within that plan
yes you want to come in
chairman if i'm if i can just add two
points to that yes
the uh the drainage system runs into the
barrett david wilson homes site adjacent
and in turn
runs north east and some of the delay
associated with
the delivery of this is to do with the
provision
of the pumping station that they have
there
and there have been some material supply
issues associated with this so
the provision of the site in practice
relies upon that
drainage facility being able to connect
our system into it
so we are holding to that and designed
this in conjunction with their engineers
so that that works
just to add to the lighting point it's
also true that we've been in discussion
with suffolk county council around the
potential for remote
operation of the lighting at ours to be
agreed and this is still ongoing as part
of a discussion with the assets team
about
a potential lease with the surgery so
there is active discussion around this
the lighting design has been done in
discussion with
county highways colleagues so it's
standard operation there and there is
the potential for that to be operated
it's an agreed time uh to uh be run
remotely by suffolk county council thank
you jim
thank you and next up is cancer madison
thank you um yeah on the um
the the late papers um the the wallpaper
parish council seemed to raise some
some interesting points about the usage
of the car park
and i've read the officer's comment on
that
and i just wondered um to what extent we
need to
express a view about that
today ahead of the lease negotiations
chairman if i if i come in on that um
the uh the opportunity you have here is
to perhaps add an informative note
which might cover the points that you
are you would wish
us to take away to the assets team
regarding those negotiations
um clearly there has been some concern
i've seen that and
uh the applicant has confirmed that the
management plan has proposed is actually
uh informative and and in draft terms so
it was meant to aid consideration of
this i think it set a little bit of a
hair running and
the reality is that there is a least
negotiation with the surgery about
operation of the car park there is a
willingness for that car park to be
available to the community including the
school
and that's as much as i know about those
negotiations at this point
uh councillor mansour you were next
uh thank you chair um i've got a number
of questions
um first one is about lighting
uh the diagram that you've got in your
papers and was on the presentation
on slide nine doesn't cover the whole
site
um and i'm assuming that the purple bit
is meant to be sort of unlit and there
appear to be
some of the motorcycle spaces and the
cycle area
are shaded in purple and they're below
the bottom of your slide i've had to
look on the papers on the
portal to see those and i wondered um
why they were they were in the dark
second question
is about the gate can you please tell me
how
cyclists get past the gate should it be
locked
because it's meant to be a cycle through
route
third question is the access from the
existing wool pit health center car park
you said is an emergency access is that
an emergency access
forever you know as in when the new
access
is is is made available
will that still remain to be in
emergency access and
is the um the fact that the construction
traffic will be coming through the
new existing develop the new development
is that conditioned
or are we just expecting it to happen
that way anyway thank you
thank you councillor mattel um i'll go
through those questions
if i could get the um the plan up again
if that's okay
um have you got oh i can move this
myself sorry
um
oh i've lost it
oh sorry
um sorry counselor yes to deal with your
first question
um the lighting plan it doesn't show the
whole car park that's due to my
technical inability
because the plan does show the whole car
park and it's been cut off unfortunately
i do regret that
and i think that if you look at the um
the overall plan
um it does show that that illumination
area
includes the the piece in the bottom
left-hand corner so that the bikes would
be covered by that
only six of the um cycle hoops
are in the white shading the rest are
all covered
coloured purple on the one that's on the
portal
right so some of the presumably that
purple is the dark
um and so most of the cycle racks are
not
covered in the white area on the plan i
don't think you should read the purple
areas being completely dark because i
think what's happened is that
they've just drawn that area around the
car park itself in order to show the the
level of illumination
within the physical area of the car park
so i i dare say
that although the air the the the
lights are pointing towards the car park
or in towards a car park
the um the actual area behind those
lights it wouldn't be completely pitch
black
it would be you know it's just that
there's not a load of illumination
coming down but i take the point
about the issue of the cut the cycling
and i think that's
a note that obviously we could take away
if you wanted that to be addressed as
part of the lighting design
which is covered by a condition on the
outline anyway
so hopefully that could be resolved um
with regard to the the gate issue
um
that's the one um with regard to the
gate issue yeah the gates
here there would be a pedestrian act
well i think the outline planning
permission requires that there is
a cycle and pedestrian access provided
in perpetuity anyway
it's the vehicular access which would be
a temporary arrangement
so there is a permanent route through
and the gate would sit
where you see my my my red dot so it
would sit on the carriageway
but this piece here would be unimpeded
so there would be
access through at that point and that
point um
similarly the gates here would be across
that point and that point so that piece
there or that route through would be
unimpeded
to pedestrians and cyclists and there's
no proposal to have a gate here
or here so hopefully that's addressed
that one
the emergency access use
it's i mean the access would exist and
it would be gated
but i think the point of the condition
would be that um
it would only be used for emergency
purposes
as and when required by the the health
center
in all honesty um but it will be apart
you know
apart from times when that is required
all access would take place through here
um and i think that that is established
through the outline
um so i think we're fairly comfortable
with that
um the construction traffic we're just
going to come in bradley on that point
but you just want to come in thank you
chairman
yes so so the the access to the surgery
has been an
evolving idea over time
and at the outset
we were keen to ensure that
we could get vehicular access into the
car park area
so that people could both
potentially receive vaccination and
staff
from the surgery could attend to any
medical emergencies that might arise
during that process
um it was a concern from
david wilson homes that there will be
traffic going through their site
and at this point in time we have not
received the transfer of that land from
them
so uh that is under their control
uh in terms of access availability
so the emergency access has been
described this morning
the temporary accesses it was originally
conceived was
uh to be to allow for
access until such time as access to the
north became
available now obviously the world has
moved on things have changed it still
remains sensible to have that potential
so from your point of view this morning
we're recommending that we control it
to emergency use
because the temporary activity well it
depends entirely on when barrett
deliver their homes and are content that
access can come through to the north
i wouldn't wish this committee to
prevent that potential if that serve the
vaccination purpose
that we need to achieve here and so from
from our point of view it's appropriate
to control longer-term access
i must bear in mind that the surgery is
private land and we wouldn't wish to see
that become
abused as an access point and it
therefore needs to be controlled so that
it's used for um prudent purposes
and not as a general through route thank
you
thank you uh any other questions from
councilman
that haven't been answered yeah yeah the
the the
was the construction management um being
uh construction traffic route being
conditioned or are we just expecting it
to happen
but can i come back on this cycle access
through the gate
it's all very well saying there's a
pavement but there's only one drop curb
on the northern uh bit of pavement
so you're expecting cyclists to hop up
onto the pavement
in front of pedestrians uh to get round
the gate is not the most ideal
situation um so that i just wanted to
come back
it's all very well saying they're going
by the pavement but you haven't made it
easy for them
i understand the point you're making on
that particular cancer i'm just
mindful of the fact you haven't had a
response on the um
on the thing about the construction
traffic in that particular case
i think that there's a construction
environmental management plan as you'd
expect from the
the outline but i don't see any issue
with us actually making that
clear in any informative that you know
that is as i understand
it to be agreed but just to reinforce
that would be no issue to add that as an
informative
council of war boys you were next
thank you chairman and thank you for
presentation uh
it's really a bit of a carry on from
that which has been
partially answered for me i think by the
uh
the details about the emergency access
or the the temporary access
to me would have made sense
for the vehicle for there to be a
permanent vehicle access from the
health center car park i should imagine
if it's
under its control then it can be used as
a
as an over spilled car part for vehicles
turning into the health center
who would actually be able to carry on
through into this car park and prevent
vehicles being parked on the road
leading up to the health center um
it's it's the business of it i think
it's been an emergency
route it to me it seems a sensible
alternative route to the
the northern route through the
residential area
i i understand the point you make making
council boys i think
the access through access as a through
route through the existing car park to
the surgery would not necessarily be
uh ideal from a highway engineering
point of view
so in terms of patience of the surgery i
suspect in the long term
they will be directed to use this car
park
and more vulnerable users and staff may
well be
directed to use the access onto
the the surgery's main main current
access
i would suggest that accessing traffic
going two-way through the surgery car
park the geometry is
quite challenging i think with a 90
degree bend and it's not designed as a
through route
so i think the prudence is not to
encourage traffic to do that
though i understand what you're saying
thank you thank you no thank you very
much
councillor field you were next
thank you uh okay we've covered cyclists
just
i noticed there's a need for disabled
parking places the parish council
suggests they could be more in the uh
in the health center car park itself but
just interesting is where is the access
for people in wheelchairs or whatever
between
the health center and the this car park
and
and perhaps between the school and this
car park um
you know i assume that they too have
dropped curbs and a lack of gates and
the various uh
things we're talking about could you
just make that clear
could you put the door up again sorry
yes thank you councillor um in terms of
the uh car park crew here as i say the
the
the vehicular access would be temporary
the pedestrian and
cycling where i think the condition says
pedestrian
or pedestrians stroke cycling access
so there's some form of access will be
through there
but the access would be on the
the pathways you can see through here
so you wouldn't actually be running
through the um the carriageway you'd be
separate
from the carriageway and similarly
there'd be
access through there and there and
through the top for pedestrians
well in terms of the access themselves
um they would be
um pavement i assume that would be
accessible to all users i think that
would be the idea so
i know that the the the hatching you can
see here for example this would be
tarmac i assume
um this well i think it's hard
landscaping proposal it doesn't actually
say
what the treatment of these is i assume
that would be blacktop
but this is um
level slabs so these would be just
demarcated
in a different material i think philip
just wants to come in on this as well
thank you chairman yes so um as i
understand it that the surfacing tension
is
is conventional blacktop um that
is intended to ensure this is delivered
to a price that is
uh appropriate and clearly we we have a
funding point with this
the reason this application is before
you today ahead of the consultations
closing
is that there is a syllabid related to
this and time from our perspective as
officers is of the essence
so the general surfacing is expected to
be to blacktop and i expect that to be
level and available for people
transiting between the surgery and the
car park
um and that should enable that
if i just pick up on council mansell's
point about
cyclists having to bunny hop as as a as
an aficionado of the activity myself i
think
this is a reserve matters application
and it is perfectly possible to take
that away and to redesign that
detail and for that to be something
which could be the subject of a
condition on this
to ensure that is provided that's
perfectly within the scope of a decision
on this reserve matters
if that's what members would like to see
and it certainly seems sensible
although i welcome some thoughts from
councillor manchester about what she
might
wish to see as a way of dealing with
that thank you
next council muller um bradley can you
just confirm please that
on the entrance exit once the building
work is finished on the actual site
that's in progress at the moment
will that have a barrier with it or that
be open all the time
thank you
thank you councillor the the permanent
access
um the plan that you've been looking at
today
does show gates and a height restrictor
but
i think that the actual provision of
those
judging from the comments we've received
locally and parish council
that will be an issue to be looked at
within the management plan in all
honesty
i think that if eventually that sort of
feature does go in there then that's
part of that
that overall approval that you would be
granted for the reserve matters
okay we have no other questions so we're
going to move on
so we now move on to the parish council
councillor geek you're going to speak as
a parish councillor first
over to you
thank you chair um yes i'm also a member
of orpik parish council as well as being
a district councillor
um the proposed car park for willpit
health center is generally
supported by the parish council but as
you've noticed there are some concerns
in relation to its use
now there is of course an urgent need
for more parking at the health centre
both for the current covert vaccination
program
and for the rise in patient numbers in
the 23 parishes it serves
but it's also been agreed by all sides
that it will be a public car park too
this has been accepted both in the draft
management plan and in all the meetings
of the parish council so far
and it's hinted at in paragraph 10.2 of
your committee report
we feel that this is the right thing to
do especially as public money is to be
used to build it
now we do understand that future
management is not part of the reserve
matters but
the terms of that draft management plan
have raised concerns
and we'd like to make you aware of our
views at this stage
if there are specific opening hours
enforceable by gates
which can be decided by mid-suffolk
district council as the owner
but operated by another party via a
lease agreement
the car park won't be available to the
public out of those hours
and to give a kind of concrete example
um the car parks within 400 meters of
the village hall
whose uh the village hall's adjoining
car park the current car park is at the
end of a no-through road
and it's frequently congested we feel
that surely the more
hours that car park can be used the new
car park can be used the more cars we
can get out of our congested village
center
the better in addition we hope the
village primary school will use it for
dropping off pupils in a much safer
environment than the current
lorry route of heath road and we're
concerned that the school has not yet
been involved in design and access
discussions
similar questions arise about the
lighting of the car park both as to
hours required control of the circuit
and the payment for electricity
lighting a car park when it's not
available for use
isn't in anyone's interest and then
finally we're pretty
pleased to see the provision of electric
vehicle points for charging electric
cars
but we note that there's no provision
for the operation of such points
their management is not yet covered
within the draft management plan and we
feel that's an oversight
thank you thanks very much
uh okay any questions for the ward
number
no sorry not the ward member the parish
councillor and my apologies that's just
a habit isn't it
okay thank you very much um so we'll now
move on
um uh as we have no questions for the
parish council we don't have an objector
but we or a supporter or the applicant
so i now ask the ward members to speak
first of all go to councillor mansell
uh thank you um it's really good to see
that this project
is being brought forward early as a
response to the kovid pandemic
whilst it is not ideal for the access to
this new car park to be
from the heath road access through the
health center car park
this is the only solution available at
present
it is essential for the temporary
vehicle access to remain as a permanent
access for pedestrians and cyclists as
this will form a useful route to promote
active travel within the community
we must not forget that this new new car
park
is not just for wool pit residents it
will serve residents from 23 parishes
within the catchment area for the health
centre uh
the la a large proportion of those who
are from elswell
in the long term this car park will be
accessed by our old stone market road
so those elmsworld residents will not
have to travel through the
congested centre of warpit to get to the
health centre which is a great advantage
there are the concerns within the
community about the management plan for
the car park and we understand that
these
outside the planning process and are not
material to any decision made today
but we hope that there will still be
ongoing discussion uh to make sure that
those conditions uh the management plan
will be acceptable to the community in
the parish council i do have concerns
about the gate of the vehicular
entrances to the car park
um from the plans uh there is no way for
cyclists to get past the gates other
than
bunny hopping onto the pavement um so
that's not ideal so i do hope that these
can be addressed
maybe these accesses should also be
level slab like the other pedestrian
cycle access points
the temporary access via the existing
health center carpet park car park i
think should be controlled by the health
centre in the long term
if this car park is to be used as a
drive-through vaccination center
um it would make much more sense if it
was
in one way and out the other way but we
would certainly not want it to be in
general use
as accessed from heathrow the existing
car park will still of course be there
and maybe it might be suitable for a
disabled parking area as it is much
closer to the health centre building
itself
i also have concerns about the lighting
arrangements as i said before the plan
printed on slide nine
only covers part of the area doesn't
show the entrance nor the southern row
of motorcycle spaces and cycle racks
um it is useful for cyclists to be able
to see when they unlock their bike
especially
if like me they have a number thing and
i can't see the numbers if it's dark
and whilst a balance needs to be made
between the safety of
people using the car park and harm to
biodiversity and light pollution
surely in this day and age we should be
using a smart lighting solution
so the car park does not need to be lit
at all times
only when it is necessary i'm sure that
is within
the bounds of technology of today that
we can have a smart lighting
solution um but on the whole this is a
great project and i
i am supportive of it but we it would be
nice to get it
perfect thank you thank you i'm going to
go to the other ward member before we
take questions for the world members in
case
something comes out so councillor geek
over to you
[Music]
thank you chair unsurprisingly i'd like
to start off by saying i'd like to
support the comments made by the parish
council
and by councillor matsel and i'll just
add a few of my own
i can only concur with councillor
mansell's view that this car park is
primarily to allow residents of other
villages to drive to the health centre
without inconvenience either to them or
to woolpit residents
wool pit's main entrance interest in
this car park as shown by the comments
from the parish council
is in the other perhaps secondary uses
of the car park by woolpit residents
as a school drop-off area as an overflow
car park for village hall events
as a visitors car park for the
surrounding estate and so on
the village hopes that it will keep
traffic away from the congenital
congested
center and that is why the actual
practical use is of more worry than the
physical form
but there are still aspects of the
physical form that affect the use
councilor mansell's talked about the
gates if those are to be installed
they shouldn't impede the use of the
road as a cycle path
i would like to add also the height
barrier no consultation has taken place
with the school and we don't know
whether access for hire vehicles such as
buses and minibuses would be helpful to
the school
but still those are matters more for the
lease agreement than for the committee
today
and i'd just like to end by emphasizing
that the village and indeed the whole
ward and the wider area is very much in
favor of this car park and would love
you to support
it but while leaving as many options
open for the widest use of this publicly
funded facility as possible
thank you
thanks very much do you have any
questions for the ward members yes
councilor madison and councillor field
thank you um yeah i i mean
obviously and very agreeing in this
hearing all the points about making sure
it's a proper
through route for cyclists and so on and
the uses um
i wonder whether the discussions about
the the
the usage and the gates and one thing in
another had
taken into consideration the unfortunate
possibility
of the car park being used for um
nighttime boy racers and handbrake turns
and like
like things which unfortunately do
plague other car parks
um what i think i'd like to do is apply
the principle
if it's not yet broke don't fix it we've
got several other car parks in woolpit
which are used by people who like to
meet and chat
often about small cars and i live
opposite one
um you know only about 10 feet away
people people like to meet up and talk
about cars and it's not illegal
we don't have handbrake turns as yet and
i'm sure that if we did and we had noise
and
upset and misery we would seek to solve
that position that
that problem when it arose so
let's cross at bridge when we come to it
if possible rather than
kind of looking like we're expecting it
to happen which might encourage it
oh look they think that's going to
attract handbrake turns
i haven't done a handbrake turn for ages
that's my principle
thank you next question is
councilorfield
thank you very pleasing to hear a
sensible attitude being taken
um i think the question's possibly more
for the officers than anyone else
it's a bit difficult to understand why
we're in quite such a rush
for this because i can't see it getting
built before we're out of the covid
vaccination period but i think uh
mr isabel did give another reason that
sounded fairly genuine
um the real question must be that the
the parish has made a lot of
sensible comments as have the ward
members how do we make sure that if we
approve this today
that those comments really get carried
forward and some sensible work is done
to resolve things you know in accordance
with the wishes of the local population
as well as getting the thing done in
time to meet financial deadlines yeah
that was the
first thing on my list for when we go
into debate uh we've heard lots of
proposals come forward
lots seem to all make sense it's just
how do we tie it all up but maybe mr
israel would like to pick up on the
first point and come on to that now
[Music]
thank you yes so um in terms of
the urgency question i think
discussions around december this year
led to a desire generally on part of
the council to deliver this car park
obviously the planning commission
existed
it would have been delivered at some
point uh the question was whether it
could serve a purpose
and discussions have been going on by
the health authority about the
vaccination program
which at that time were not fixed or
necessarily known but clearly there was
a model which
orbit surgery operated operating from
the nearby industrial estate with a
drive-through vaccination program for
flu
that was seen as a model that worked and
the opportunity to use this car park
to support a vaccination program was
seen as being a good thing to
address and prioritize since january
therefore um
there's been a project group working on
this to try and identify obstacles and
identify
solutions and and work out how to
achieve this
now um the reality of the situation is
that
uh we are to some degree beholden to
the build of the residential estate i
mentioned the drainage issue
to councillor castin earlier and that is
a
timing question which we have to respect
because the site will positively drain
in that direction
the access to is also an issue because
at this point in time
uh the district council does not own the
land there is a section 106 under the
outline which transfers it
to the district council upon occupation
of dwellings but they have not yet
happened however
in fairness to barrett david wilson
homes they have been more than willing
to
work constructively with us to explore
the opportunities to provide that
they too have been hostage to what we
can all see in the real world around
materials supplies and those are
a real challenge for us in trying to
deliver
uh a car park here so all of those
things have been
ticking away as as issues we have been
exploring whilst
the vaccination program has been rolled
out nationally um
so we have expedited and accelerated the
time frame for delivery of this car park
but it was always intended to be
provided at some point in
time at the moment conversation is
evolving into a conversation around
delivering the
booster program because that is seen as
being necessary through the end of the
year into next year
and i think my own uh sense of uh any
any virus is that it will mutate and the
science is the science
so there is likely to be a continued
need for this
um the question then of um enabling uh
this site to operate is partly uh health
efficiency
because for some of the vaccination
programs uh having health staff on site
has been a desirable thing in order to
deal with anaphylactic shock and the
like
and when you're operating remotely from
uh the
business park uh clearly you have to
take site staff away from the surgery
when they could be doing other things at
the surgery
and be you know a short walk from this
site
rather than having to be kept available
at another location
so we think there is uh quite a degree
of common sense around
around that those are just some of the
issues that sit behind the timetabling
of this
we are hostage to quite a few things but
i think it's fair to say
almost all of the parties barrett david
wilson the county council
and others have worked constructively to
try and bring this forward in a timely
way
it was always granted planning
permission before the pandemic existed
and it was always seen as supporting a
need which was
desirable to support surgery i think
what's happened is that has brought it
into sharp focus and we have an
opportunity
thank you chairman thank you any other
questions for the ward members
yeah councillor caston
thank you very much mr chairman um i
just wondered
how far roughly probably this is one for
councillor geek
um how far roughly the primary school
was from this
car park and whether it's a um
credible alternative to parking outside
the school
that is an interesting question because
the access and the path
don't currently exist so it's not a
route i've ever walked
um i can only suggest that we see if we
can find something on the here we go
on the slide four is an excellent one
um so if you can see
uh oh because we've got no scale but the
form from the health from the car park
site to the edge of the
um map is probably about 200 meters
so i would guess it's at the very most
200 meters
what people who are more used to looking
at plans what do you think
let's get a a country opinion for
councilmember or
matching opinion what's it going to be
the google earth picture um and
um i'd say yeah it from the health
center from the if you look at the line
of the hedge line on a google earth
picture which i think you've got on your
slideshow bradley um there's a sort of
straight hedge line which i'd say
looking at the scale on my screen is
about 200 meters from the corner of the
health center
to the existing woolpit primary school
and of course last month we
we um granted permission for that um
school extension which is out the back
there so i'd say yeah it's about 200
meters
from the edge of the car park thank you
very much for that
okay any other questions for the ward
members
no okay so we've heard from everyone
that's going to speak today and we've
also had all the papers and
put before us so it's over to us to
discuss debate and come to a conclusion
can i just ask um go straight in and
just ask we've
heard questions i've i've made a list
here we've heard questions around
lighting access alternative use
cycling uh parking in terms of lighting
and
access for cycling pedestrian access
construction traffic
and we've said a lot of these we can
either do informative notes or pick them
up later how can we wrap
all those points up so that and the
lighting in terms of times of lighting
and how the lighting would operate
how can we wrap all those up because
they are all
items that actually we should be able to
deliver but it's just about how do we
get it into the recommendation and make
sure that does happen
chairman i suppose what i would suggest
is that
certainly if you are minded to uh
follow the the the the concerns of the
parish council
i would suggest he would add an
informative which would say that the
committee
would wish those concerns to be
addressed
as a practical matter in giving effect
to this decision
and that's one option
so that simply wraps together quite a
number of issues which
do not have a specific issue but
effectively would hopefully
and i will take that that away but
that's certainly
one informative um i'm going to struggle
a little on the construction management
side and turn back to
bradley in relation to that but as
regards cycling and bunny helping with
the gate it might be sensible as i
suggested to for officers to include a
condition
which says something to the effect of
not withstanding any detail shown on
on the drawing regarding the gate to the
northern entrance to the site
provision shall be made for cycle access
when the gates are closed and we can
certainly take that away
um but i think that's question whether
that's what
councilman mansell is particularly
focused on around that point and whether
that would work for her
so can we in the informative actually
ask that
the officers liaise with the parish
council
and the primary school just to look at
what is the best solution for that
car park outside of the operating house
of the surgery
yes yeah thank you i've got councillor
uh muller first then cancer maths
thank you um yeah i'm more than happy
with this particular application and i
will be
more than happy to recommend approval of
this application subject to what um
mr isabella's has just sort of informed
this committee
that's basically it thank you thank you
council madison
this um on the the wording that
again echoing noises oh it might be this
um the um
the the mr isabel suggested about the
cycling the ones that i wrote down
earlier
um as a condition was really that the
there should be a through route for
cyclists 24
7 um with level access
including when the gate is is shut if
the gate
appears um because i think there was a
definite intention that this would
add to the the cycle infrastructure of
of will pet
um and while i'm speaking i think the
the point about the 23 villages
people coming in to use the health
center
i think probably not quite as many but
the same thing applies in in relation to
the school of course that
people will be coming in for a number of
other villages
um shield bringing children in to the
primary school so
i think that um that just emphasizes the
point about the
liaison uh including the school thank
you
okay so i'm just going to run through
this just so that we're absolutely clear
so it's been proposed by account and
we'll others can come in
it's been proposed by council members
second by council matheson
but um following the recommendations on
page 25 of our papers but with an
informative note
that discussions take place between the
parish council of the school the surgery
and mid-south district council around
the the availability of the car park
outside of the
surgery hours that access
is looked at in terms of cycling
with a level access with lighting to be
determined
uh but smart lighting to be determined i
think we should call it
um construction traffic's already been
taken care of i think
uh with we already have that as a
standard um
standard condition um
and then in terms of the temporary
access
and it becoming a permanent access and
how those gates are going to work so
those are the
key things that i've got that are listed
on my list
is there anything i've missed out cancer
warboys
no chairman thank you i think that's an
excellent list uh
just a couple of suggestions really that
perhaps uh
the feasibility of um bollards would be
better than a gate because that would
leave the access open for pedestrians
cyclists and wheelchairs
but prevent motor vehicles traveling
backwards and forwards
um the i do think the the
the community asset aspect of this is
really very important and support what
the ward members have
said um
[Music]
my other suggestion is perhaps we looked
at the where the ev
charging points are to look at whether
these
could be solar dv solar port
charging bays similar to the ones we've
deployed in stone market that might be
require different wiring to just put in
a straightforward ev charging point
whether that's
provisions make for it which would
offset the costs of running the ev
charging points
okay so we just asked the ev charging
points to look at to try and find the
most economical
system and um the bollards yeah that's a
great idea i suspect i'm going to be
told that those bolas are hugely
expensive compared to a gate but i think
that's
that would that would that absolutely
answers the problem of cyclists and push
chairs
getting through very simply so we'll
leave that with uh
yeah please do
[Music]
sorry i mean perhaps if members want to
carry on and i come in at the end that
might be most useful because
there are some things that can come back
either sure cancer field you want to
come in
agree with most of what's been said so
far i'm inclined to say well let's stop
debating and get on with it
um time is of the essence and let's get
moving
i'll just add something on bollards an
excellent solution
but in my past experience is
horrendously unreliable
so if you want an access which is
available a few days a week when the
bollards are working
and that's the right way to go if you'd
like one that's working all the time
a gate is more primitive but reliable
okay thank you okay anyone else wish to
speak before we go
back to philippi yep uh cancer uh cast
and i'll bring matheson back
just a um just a couple of points um i
don't want to be
too negative because um i
i will be voting for this unless some
something else comes up in debate
but um i do feel a little bit
um uncomfortable with doing this before
the consultation
period ends i can understand why we're
doing it
um i i'd like to know that if something
did come up it would um
it would definitely come back to
committee because it's not
really how things are supposed to work
um
the the lighting plans i'm not
particularly happy with i don't
i don't think they really give me what i
need from those um
with those purple areas um which
make it look like there's no light it
doesn't really cover the waste light
which i think is a really important
issue
for the houses surrounding this um i'd
like to see
i'd like to see the lighting um the
diagram
go out further than the um the um
the car park to see what pollution there
is
but um this is much needed provision
it's um if i don't think there's a
primary
school in the whole of mid-suffolk that
wouldn't welcome anything
that helps them um for
dropping off children and blocking up
the roads there's so many problems so
i would really welcome that to be them
to be
spoken to in this um process um
cyclists becoming pedestrians for
10 seconds doesn't really concern me too
much
i can understand why um we want the
smooth flow of
cyclists um into there but um as a
cyclist
it doesn't worry me that at the end of
my journey i'd have to get off my bike
lift it onto a pavement and become a
pedestrian over the pavement
but i will say anything that lets some
cycles in will let motorbikes in which
could potentially be a
issue in a residential area but
i'm yeah in favor of this it's good um
yeah um i don't i i agree with what all
the other councillors have said
and um yeah i'm ready for the vote
yeah thank you casa matson after you we
will go to the vote yes if if
councillor mullers agree well i was
hoping we could just
put the magic words at all times into
the
um the part about cycling and level
access
um phrasing yeah i suggest we hear from
mr isabel all the points that have been
raised and just see what the wording is
then we can
ask you two to comment mr israel over to
you
thank you thank you chairman um so
it's a reserve matters application that
you're looking at the use of this was
looked at with the outline there is
nothing on here which
debars it i don't think you can impose a
condition
to prescribe that now but you can add an
information to expect that to be
made available and clearly the surgery
have a right to say no
if they don't wish to allow access to
their car park that is
their prerogative or to control how it
is so
i don't think you can dedicate this to
to public access in quite that way
and i would be aware of doing that but i
think it's perfectly reasonable
for committee to um approach this as
as as adding an informative suggested
chairman
and in terms of wording i'd suggest that
that informative says that
the committee requests officers to work
with parish council surgery and school
to resolve appropriate availability and
management of the car park and its
lighting
and and use um uh in delivering
in delivering the facility that would
seem to me to give everybody
the ability to negotiate this in a
practical sense which i think is what's
required
um because ultimately there has to be a
lease for the car park in order to
deliver it
um as we're anticipating so
that's my suggestion for an informative
chairman in terms of
the point about the gate and the bollard
i still think that we have we have a we
have a gate before you don't have a
bollard before you
decide the application in front of you
would be my advice
and i would say as far as cycling goes
you are perfectly at liberty to add a
condition and we'd recommend it
to say notwithstanding any detail within
this application
the detail for the gate area to the
northern access shall enable
enable safe and level access by bicycle
when the gate is closed
in a manner which should have been
agreed by the local planning authority
before before the use commences
then on the question of the surgery and
the emergency access
can i suggest as we're in a an
uncertainty around
the availability of the northern access
because of the delivery of the
barrett dave wilson site what i'd
suggest is a condition that allows for
access to the surgery
for emergency or temporary purposes
which should have been agreed in writing
by the local planning authority in
advance so that
we have both the potential for temporary
access and the potential for emergency
access but not permanent access through
that car park
i'm not sure how close i've got to what
members wanted
thank you so in effect we've got one
informative and two conditions correct
are you happy with that customer yes
thank you chad i am happy with it and
council madison you're happy with that
okay on that basis
i think we'll go to a vote as i have no
other hands up so
it's been proposed by councillor muller
seconded by council madison as per the
recommendations
uh sorry on page 25
with the additional informative that
we've just had read out along with the
conditions on the cycling and the
access on that basis i think we'll go to
a vote and we'll ask
the government's officer to take the
vote please
thank you chair so what i've put in
modern.gov is that
application dc 2102564 be approved as
detailed in the updated officer
recommendation
with the additional conditions and
information as read out by the chief
planning officer
is that acceptable chair thank you so if
members could please go to the
mobile.gov app
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner of today's agenda
this will bring up the subsection on
voting slash attendance
and there you will see the vote in
progress colored in a light blue color
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is
seven votes for and unanimous
lovely thanks very much okay so um
normally we try and take a
break every 90 minutes uh i realized
every hour and a half i realized we're
going to be going for an hour and 10
minutes but i suspect rather than
breaking up the next application we take
a quick 10 minute break now
start again at 10 to 11 please for the
next application
just please remember to associate
distance as we leave this chamber
or use the facilities thank you
right welcome back everyone okay we're
now going to look at uh
agenda item 7b uh dc210a
366. and hand over the case officer
daniel cameron daniel over to you
thank you chair yes this is application
dc 2100 366. it's for land to the south
of west thorpe road in finnegan
and it's an application made in outline
with all matters reserved with the
erection of up to eight dwellings with
garages
um so here we have the um
site plan here you can see the linear
run of development to the north side of
westhalk road
immediately opposite the site and we
have residential development
immediately adjacent and we have a
expanse of field immediately adjacent
and i'll come to that in a moment
because the aerial maps
provided here are slightly out of date
with what's actually on site
here we take the wider view we can see
uh the field pattern
um extending away to the west of the
site off towards west thorpe
and we can see the rest of the
settlement pattern of the village of
finningham as well to the east
i'll come now to a more recent um aerial
view and you'll see that there is
work going on on the site immediately
adjacent to
the application site the application
sites here
in 2018 outline planning permission was
given for this site and that received
reserve mata's
approval in 2019 um and his
development is currently underway for
the action of six units on this
on this site here and you'll see in the
images later members
that development is well advanced and
you'll also get a clear idea of the
appearance of that development as well
if we look at the site location plan
again we can see that laid out
i mean here we have three plots
and then three plots
and if i come now to the constraints map
members i'll talk you through these
so we have the brown line here that
demotes the um
existing settlement boundary of
finningham you can see that it does not
include the adjacent site
to this one or the site that we're
looking at here we have a public right
of way
that crosses down the boundary of the
site and i'll show you some images of
that later as well members
and then we've got the two orange
buildings as well particularly notable
this is hill house it's a grade two
listed building um immediately adjacent
to the site on the other side of the
road
and then we have this one here which is
a white horse public house
we'll come now to the joint local plan
you can see the purple line here
extends the settlement boundary much as
it is
it doesn't extend around the adjacent
site and obviously doesn't include
this site here and i'll come to that
issue in a moment
as well we've also got two allocations
for housing development within the
village
we've got one to the eastern side and
one to the north
i'll quickly run you through the site
plans
obviously as an outline application we
have the redline site plan
and we've also been provided with a site
plan it's a little difficult to see
here immersive apologies might be
clearer in your bundle
there's a gray line that runs along the
frontage of the site
and that's the point at which the
developer has agreed that
within the any reserve matters that
might come forward nothing greater than
single story and height would be placed
on that
on that portion of the site so i think
if we turn now to
a few of the issues that are raised just
in terms of the calling on the site we
obviously have three
quite clear issues in terms of the sites
outside the settlement boundary for the
village
both in the adopted development plan and
in the emergent joint local plan
it wasn't brought forward in the call
for sites to support the
emergence of the joint local plan and
also the the limited nature of the
services and facilities in finning
village itself
those issues are dealt with in greater
detail in sections three and four of
your report members
however i just wanted to bring a few
points to your attention in that
obviously we have the adjacent sites
obviously granted
um 2018 and then reserve matters in 2019
um i think members
we might be on a slightly um
difficult road if we were to say um
looking at the the the planning history
for the area
if the adjacent site has been found to
represent sustainable development why
would the adjacent site not be
um and i think as well we need to turn
some attention to the joint local plan
in that if we have allocated housing
development within the village of
finningham
are we also saying that there is
sufficient access to services and
facilities for those two
allocations um
to look slightly at the call for sites
issue i'll
quickly scroll back just to get an
overhead
in case it's clearer we actually have a
maid footway
um that runs and you'll see this in the
site images as well members that runs
along the north side of west thorpe road
and provides a connection down to the
public house
and we've also got sort of a small small
holding shop for selling
produce there and obviously we've got
the main bus stops within finning and
there as well the frequency of the
services are obviously limited
if i come on to the images of the site
because i think they'll probably help
you understand some of the other issues
with the development slightly more here
we have a view
along west thorpe road looking into
finning him
um the house on the left-hand side of
the image
that is hill house that's a grade two
listed building and
in the distance members you can see the
six units
currently being developed on the
adjacent sites
i think this image and the next image
also gives you a good indication of the
topography of the site
we've got a slight incline from the
highway
to the field and you can see that that
increases
as you move along the road into the
village
you can see that slightly better here um
and this will come on to another issue
here as well
as you move around this bends we
obviously move down
and then we have another bend and then
you start to
move up as well you can see a little bit
of
parking on the road associated with the
development of the adjacent site
in the conditions members you'll note
that there's a condition requiring a
construction management plan
such if we were to
approve the application before us today
we would have detail of on-site parking
provided
in advance of any development commencing
on site such
we could look to avoid issues such as on
strike
on-site parking contractors vehicles
i've shown you this image members this
is taken um
from google street view and it's dated
2011. um
so it's the view along west top road um
towards west up we can see hill house
quite prominent on that corner there
and we can see actually the field as it
would have been prior to the granting of
outline
and reserve matters um on the adjacent
site and i think
actually if we look at it from the other
the other view as well we can see
there's been a
there's been a stark change to that
landscape
through the granting of of planning
permission
on that adjacent site
i'll push slightly further on here's a
view from hill house across
the site you can see the back corner of
the adjacent development
on the left hand side of the screen and
then this is the run of the the public
footpath
it's very much a path that just runs
along the field quite typical
there's no um sort of additionality to
it is
looking to provide that crossing and
connection into the wider public
rights-of-way network
i think at this point this is an image
taken closer to that bend
and you can see the cars and vans of
contractors parked there
but also this sort of a darker area just
behind that's an element of standing
water on the highway
this is a known issue with this bend
in effect road drainage
for this point of the highways network
feeds into a gully and then into a
manhole
the manhole is about a meter deep and a
meter in diameter
and it's likely not sufficient for the
amount of water that it needs to cope
with
um hence the standing water in the road
if we come on here are some images
provided
by neighbours to the neighboring the
adjacent development
obviously this is a quite peak time
in terms of water but i think it gives
members some idea
as to the potential for standing water
in the highway now
in terms of of that issue it's obviously
one for the highway authority to address
it's there
it's their drainage um it's within
the highway it's not possible for
for the developer of the site to
come forward and affect that without
permission from the highway authority
i'm also given to understand that the
developer has been in contact with the
neighbors opposite the um
the access to the site and where the the
issue is
um they proposed a method of dealing
with some of that standing water
in that they propose a below ground soak
away
under the neighboring property's land
that would feed into
the existing manhole for storage of
water and dispersal of water
so it will provide a secondary storage
area for water on the other side of the
road
we'll probably provide some protection
for those properties because obviously
as we can see in extreme events
the water crosses the roads and starts
to come up the curbing
but obviously members we've got that
issue where the topography of the road
slopes down towards that bend and also
away from it as well so we have water
coming into that
from two areas i think the other issue
we just need to look at and address and
forgive me for backtracking slightly is
the impact of the development on hill
house
so we have a grade two listed building
adjacent to the development side now we
have a clear idea of sort of the
the the appearance of the dwellings that
the developer has brought forward on the
neighbouring site and i don't think
there's anything
that would suggest to me that a
different design approach will be taken
here although obviously that's
something that we'd need to look at in
any subsequent application for reserve
matters
but in terms of its response to the to
the area it responds fairly well they're
fairly
attractive they're nicely appointed and
designed they're slightly more
modern in appearance you know in terms
of internal
ceiling heights and things so they have
a slightly higher ridge height than the
more
traditional dwellings on the northern
side of the road but i don't think
they're
unattractive i don't think they're
unpleasant um
we have the comments from the council's
heritage team and they obviously know a
medium level of less than substantial
harm
what they do know is that there is
potential within the reserve matters for
that level of harm to be reduced
they indicate both the addition of a
green buffer to the site frontage
and also use of
design and heights within the site to
further reduce that level of harm now
obviously
members will be aware that the mppf when
we have a less and substantial
level of harm identified there needs to
be a balancing exercise undertaken
in accordance with paragraph 196
and i'm sure that will be gone through
as you enter into your debates
i'll leave matters there and i'll leave
the um
i'll leave the images up for members so
we can go back through if there's
anything that they would like
identified in questions or might be
helpful to them in
asking their questions thank you chad
thank you if i can kick off with some
questions if i may
um so so i know we're not here to talk
about the application next door but can
you just tell us how many houses was
built there
and with this new site which is
obviously running next to it is it the
same landowner or a different landlord
because there's no affordable housing if
you
amalgamate the two sites together this
is the first question
um there's no landscape plan or anything
like that in our papers
is that because it's an outline but um
could you just explain why there isn't
one um yeah those are the two points of
this
thank you chair um if we could go back
to the um
can i just ask the third question the
third question is
you said we would have there'd be a
construction management plan
is there a construction management plan
next door because obviously they're
what we're seeing there is people
parking and trashing the
side of the road so what's happened to
the construction management plan in that
location
so um yeah so
land ownership so in terms of
london let's just make sure we flick
through the right way
um so in terms of land ownership um
we've had information submitted with the
application so this this site came
forward
for development 2018 it was in separate
ownership to the rest of the site
this has remained in that separate
ownership
we have six plots um
shown on the on the plans and from the
photos that's what we've got built out
we have the three
on that side they're very visible in
photos and then they're also three
on the other side so we've got six units
on that site and obviously we've got
some landscaping around
to the edges now members will be aware
of their policies with regards to
affordable housing where we have
artificial subdivision of a site in
order to avoid delivery of affordable
housing
policies are very clear that we would
look to reimpose the full amount of
affordable housing
on the site when the subsequent
application came forward
in this instance at no point have these
two sites ever been in the same
ownership so there's been no artificial
subdivision in that regard
i think probably it's likely that should
this site come forward
an option will then be exercised and the
developer will take it on and then bring
forward the development but
in terms of artificially subdividing it
in order to avoid
affordable housing that's never been the
intention this site came forward as six
and this site is potential for up to
eight
um if we look at landscaping yes you're
exactly right chair we've got a reserved
matters application before us so
everything we'd have matters would be
appearance
scale layout access to the highway
and also landscaping so at that point
we'd be able to
look at particularly i think what
happens along the site frontage given
the comments of heritage
but also what happens at this edge and
how
what happens at this edge creates a more
defined edge
for the development and for the village
because obviously we then move into the
countryside as we move along west.road
and also what that landscape does in
terms of the run of the footpath
[Music]
in terms of how that responds there and
and we can obviously undertake the
relevant consultations with the relevant
public rights of way team
with heritage again on submission of
reserve matters and obviously members
um if during your deliberations it's a
case of
um you are content with the principle of
development
um but are concerned about the reserve
matters well there is always the option
that you could make your determination
to be that the reserve matters would
return to committee for
approval rather than rest with officers
or if you weren't sure that that needed
to be done
at that point there is always the option
of bringing the item back to committee
through the call-in procedure
last point in terms of the construction
management plan i'm not aware
of the construction management plan
condition on the neighbouring site
but on this site given the issues around
the access
you'll see in the the last section of
your report members we do have
that added in here and i think that
covers off a number of different um
elements as well so we're looking to
make sure we understand how
contractor parking would operate how um
what provision there would be to stop
water from the site entering the highway
during construction
um hours of work hours of deliveries all
those sorts of things
um so that we can understand and control
that element of development because i
think
from the the comments that have been
received um during the application
one of the the large sort of um local
notes has been
in terms of the parking on that on that
highway verge
and also on the standing water around
the access
so i don't think we'd want to be in a
position where if we were approving the
principle we'd be looking to
repeat the experience on this bend
on this bend especially given as it runs
down into the village
okay thank you very much councillor
mansoor you want to come in with a
question
uh thank you chair uh i've got three
questions um
first question is about the uh highways
response which we've got on page 69 of
our papers
it refers to visibility displays on a
drawing
which i don't know if we've got access
to
and as i understand it this application
doesn't
include the access so how can there be a
drawing of a visibility display
second question is relating to the
footpath
on the image you've got on slide five it
looks as if the red line area
goes to the west of the footpath
but the picture on um
slides seven and nine looks like the
footpath is the western boundary
of the site so could you please clarify
where exactly this footpath
goes with relation to the site and the
third
question is on the recent aerial
photograph
it looked like there was some sort of
works to the south of the existing
development can you tell me if there's
any
planning application for any further
development down there because it looks
like it's already got some earthworks
thank you
apologies members um i'll get used to
how things work now are back
in person at some point i feel sure um
in terms of the the visibility's place
access as a reserve matters so while
highways might want to see
a plan there and certain displays
provided
because it's a reserve matter that the
point of access within the site
is subject to change so i think at this
point and
i mention it in the report in section
five
although highways have come back in
their response and noted a number of
conditions
i don't think it's quite appropriate
that we want to
require those to be provided at this
point given that
the applicant has clearly said that
access is a reserved matter and may be
subject to
to change within within the site so i
think i think from their point of view
we don't need to um we don't need to
secure that at this point but obviously
on submission of reserve matters that
would be the appropriate point that we
would
be going back checking that we have the
appropriate visibility space to meet
the requirements of highways and make
sure the access is in a
sensible location such that those
visibility displays aren't affected by
the topography of the road immediately
in front of the um
the site for their members and yeah i
agree um
the the earlier points in terms of
um the aerial mapping that's been
undertaken
um showing the site boundary i think
this is more a case of
our mapping where we've then interpreted
whether
the red line of the site runs um
is slightly out compared to the red line
that's been submitted
and in terms of um which of the two i
would use i would utilize the red line
that's been submitted by
the applicants such that
if i get to it there we go the footpath
yeah it forms it forms that boundary
i mean presumably the footpath could
form part of the site if the landowner
was so willing and the developer wanted
to take it on but in terms of
um you know additional considerations
for them then all the legal
requirements that exist around footpaths
in terms of their
temporary stopping up or diversion
during during construction works
so i think you know based on the fact
that the red line sets it as its
western boundary that is what i
interpret to be the correct
um western boundary for it so that the
footpath runs outside of it
and then if we jump slightly back to the
more recent aerial
i'm not aware of any planning
application on this site
and i think it might just be a case of
when the aerial was taken some works
were going on
within the site or crop had been
removed but i'm not aware of a planning
application
on this site and certainly from the the
joint locker plan
we don't have the the extension of the
second boundary around
anything anything there and we don't
have an allocation
made on on that site as well so i'm not
aware of anything
planned to come forward on that site
either you want to come back
yeah could i could i come back on the
highways comment because the
the letter from the highways officer
says it says before the access is first
used
visibility displays as indicated on
drawing number 561805a
well where is drawing 561805a
um it doesn't appear i can't find it on
the planning portal
does it exist has it been drawn and if
so why don't we have access to that
drawing
to see the sort of indicative visibility
displays from this
site even if it's not an actual access
as
per the planning permission
so in terms of the reserve matters
sorry i'm getting confused about what
mouse i actually need to use again i'll
get used to this
in terms of the application it accesses
reserved so
any anything that shows there's a
potential access and shows us
potential visibility displays has the
class to be changed um
the only requirement for the application
at this point is to show that an access
could be made and that's what the
highway authority are responding to in
that instance
i'm just going to try and check the
planning file for you members to make
sure
because the drawing numbers have gone
from my mind as well
no come in um
dan was it 16 a sorry
161805a okay so that's a
that's the location plan yes can we go
back to the powerpoint please
on that plan
is that okay can you hear um so i think
we've had that plan
on screen that's the one which is the
red line plan or we got the other one on
there
so if i zoom into that on my version
the what's that fine
point is in the middle but it's not very
clear
but that's the only plan we have as an
indicative plan is that not correct
yeah so that is the plan we're working
to that is the red line plan
and announce what is before us we
appreciate that often with outlines
access comes along naturally
in this case it hasn't it is all
reserved matters
we are just dealing with a red line
around a plan
and ultimately all the conditions that
are recommended by highways they haven't
sought to
resist this development in principle in
terms of traffic generation or
any particular access issues um they
have sort of conditions
but irrelevant of that they they would
have to be on the reserve matters
application
where access is reserved for so
ultimately in the principle sense that
we're dealing with this application at
outline
that we have no objection from the
highways authority and that's the
position we are
within
thank you uh council maths and you're
next
thank you yeah paragraph 4.3
refers to to bus services
and stops and um clearly
the sustainability of this um location
is is going to be important um
can we not have from somebody
um a greater degree of detail about what
what the frequency of services is
because i think too often
we get kind of vague statements about
bus services in the village and when you
get down to it
um especially in my villages it turns
out it's like
two a week or if you're lucky and um
so i think there's an award member or
somebody please
there's also a link i think on your
point about because
actually because planning permission has
been given in the nextdoor site
so does that mean it is deemed to be a
sustainable location or not if you could
just answer that as well
of course so in terms of the bus
services they're all accessed
um from stops at the white horse public
house
there's route 320 and 387
they aren't the most frequent um
[Music]
387 provides a connection towards
gizzling him on a thursday
you know monday to friday the 387 will
operate
in the morning but then additional
services are
thursdays and wednesdays
and the 320 operates monday to friday
but is a midday service to
um i so it's not
incredibly frequent it's not not served
um but in terms of um
where we are in terms of of the planning
history um
the council as local planning authority
has previously considered
development on the immediately adjacent
plot of land obviously 2018
the planning landscape was slightly
different for the council
at that point in five years in terms of
five-year housing land supply being able
to demonstrate the
the necessary five-year housing land
supply um
but obviously we've we've still assessed
it and in terms of the mppf the site has
been found to be
one that represents sustainable
development and i think
there is a there is an issue um
in that yes we are 2021 now we have the
five-year housing land supply
um we have the emergent joint local plan
coming to examination
at the back end of this month
but ultimately section three of the
report
runs through this the adopted
development plan
is not of sufficient age that can be
considered to be in full compliance with
the mppf
um and accordingly where we have
our our cs plans our our cs01 cso2
policies they're not considered to carry
sufficient weight to be ordered
in order to be determinative in their
own right at this time
we have the emergent joint local plan
coming forward
and it doesn't allocate this site but we
do have other allocations within the
village so
presumably for those allocations we've
determined that
their connection to services and
facilities including
access to to public transport is
sufficient to allow them to come forward
um and we've
you know we are unfortunately in the
position that while
the emergent joint local plan has been
closer than it's ever been to being
adopted it still is not adopted and the
degree of weight that it attracts is
limited
um you know we also want in a position
where we have a neighborhood plan that's
coming forward
within the village um so we don't have
those additional policies to to look at
or attribute weight to
um so i think section three covers that
fairly in depth for you members but i
think in terms of the planning history
of the site
in terms of the position of the village
within the joint local plan and i think
in terms of the material weight we're
able to afford
the adopted development plan that we
currently have and the emergent joint
local plan
we're in a position where unfortunately
we're relying on on the mppf and if we
found
the neighbouring site to be sustainable
um
i think were we to refuse the
application on those grounds
i think a planning inspector would quite
rightly ask us to
clearly demonstrate why the adjacent
site was acceptable
to to form sustainable development but
this site
which is not um
any different in terms of its connection
to the rest of finnegan
aside from being slightly further away
um why we've come to a different
conclusion
given the the facts before is in this
application okay
thank you okay i'm now going to move on
to
uh bring forward we have two parish
councils have been invited to speak
today
because the boundary uh the parish
boundary is very close between uh
finningham and west thorpe
so i'd now like to ask tony kilby
finningham parish council to speak
each other yes
yeah of course absolutely
so i just had a couple of questions
sorry to jump in
um yeah on page 53 of the report
paragraph 3.16
the report says that this site would
have a strong
functional relationship to the village
given that elsewhere in the report is
acknowledged that finningham doesn't
have
many services what does this statement
mean i.e what's the functional
relationship
too
um and then again
i suppose i want to um pick this
principle of development that um
daniel's just referred to 13.4 refers to
the adjacent site
and you're i think trying to piggyback
on that the fact that the principle of
development is already already there
um but to my mind there's a very
different
situation now because we have a
five-year land supply can we just sort
of
explain that a bit better thank you
so 316
in the report we're not looking at a
site that is
um particularly remote from the rest of
the village it's not
um poorly spatially related to the rest
of the village can we have the
powerpoint back please mandy
if i get my directions right
here we go i think this is useful um
you know we have this neighboring block
of development here we have something
that would visually tie into that run of
development to the south we have the
connection
along west thorpe road into the
crossroads
that obviously provides a pedestrian
route to the bus stops the public house
and the small small holding shop such as
we have it
so we're not we're not looking at
something that is is physically remote
from the
rest of the village we're not looking
for something that is um
oddly spatially related to the rest of
the village
um we obviously have the other the other
sites
um here have a good link into the
crossroads here and then obviously this
one slightly further away
put links in as well so we have a number
of
um developments within finningham
um coming forward that would
be utilizing those services and
facilities
in terms of 314
[Music]
you're absolutely right we do have the
five-year housing land supply now
[Music]
that's dealt with hopefully in the
report
but in terms of where that leaves as
members
previously we didn't have the five-year
housing land supply so the presumption
in favor of sustainable development was
automatically engaged in the
determination of applications
now we have the five-year housing land
supply so there's not an automatic
engagement
however we still have to deal with the
issue that the adopted development plan
is not of an age where it can be
completely reflective
of the mppf i mean if we look at the
core strategy that's 2008 and before the
publication of the first mppf
when we look further back at the local
plan that's 1998
and again came forward at a time well
before the mppf was ever a
a white paper or a green paper that we
might then have to look at in the future
so when we're looking at the the wording
of those policies
um they aren't in strict compliance with
what we're required to look at
with regards to the mppf and the issue
with then come up to members
is that paragraph 213 of the mppf
requires that where policies are not in
full compliance with what's required of
them by the mppf
they carry a lesser degree of material
weight and the determination of
applications
and and that's the reason why in this
instance we're looking at the
the fact that we have a sustainable
development um
going on adjacent to the site that in
terms of the principle
i don't think there are the the the
policy
i don't think there is the policy
support there for you members to say
that
um the the policies that we would
normally apply cs1
cs2 h07 have the material weight in and
of themselves
to be able to um
determine the application on their own
merit so that's why
that's why we've accepted or the report
indicates the principle of development
is acceptable for members
and why the the recommendation is given
as it is um obviously members might want
to explore those points more in debate
um but in terms of of where the
where the council's policies currently
are we are in that sort of
sticky position between we have policies
looking to come in that are fully in
accordance with the mppf but
unfortunately are afforded limited
weight
and we have policies that are still
afforded a degree of weight but not
sufficient weight to be determinative
in their own case okay thank you
sorry to have missed you out um okay
we'll try again we'll go for the parish
councils again
so as i said earlier we have tony kilby
from finning and parish council we've
also asked westlaw parish council to
light speak mr kilby you have three
minutes
and over to you thank you very much
good morning mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen um
i'd like to say to start with although
precedence has been set
by the recently completed development by
purd
burgess holmes the next to the proposed
site
we do not believe that should have any
bearing on the decision that you are
about to make
our objections are as follows the
performance of the developers
during the construction of the previous
project has not been particularly
extemporary
it disregards the restrictors of the
planning permission with regard to site
control has resulted in the
exacerbation of the flooding problem
dangerous activities on the road
and the construction of an illegal berm
uh behind the site
housing waste building material
the initial document submit submitted by
phil gobold
agent to the developer makes great play
of the fact that he had a meeting with
alex scott
of the planning officer in september
2019
and was told that the council's planning
policy was out of date
and the fact that the site is outside
the settlement boundary should
be ignored i'm not an expert on these
matters so i can be shot down
about that but it seems strange that you
can just ignore something if you don't
agree with it
and to he contends that this would be a
sustainable development
but his argument is based on flawed
information
to encourage residents to use cars he
states that there are two bus services
in the village this has already been
mentioned this morning
one of which is the service to barrister
edmonds
once a week one bus once a week
to stow market there is one bus a day
plus two on thursdays that
gentleman and ladies is not a consid i
consider to be
a service a bus service
the village itself has no shops apart
from a small
farm shop it has
a pub which has a checkered history and
is now up for sale again
there is a church but there is no
village hall for community
activities my colleague will present
other arguments but i'd like to draw
your attention to a very important issue
over the last 12 months we've had
disastrous floods in the village
one of which was outside the first
development
admittedly the construction of this
development exacerbated the situation
but this problem has been with us for
many years
and it seems that suffolk county council
are
unable or unwilling to do anything about
it
the problem lies with a sub-highway
drain which is obviously blocked or has
nowhere to go the village foul water
sewage system is unable to cope with the
existing load witnessed by the number of
times
raw sewage has been coming i'm sorry the
three minutes is up so you'll need to
have the final sentence please
well okay the question of the raw sewage
is the biggest problem out the raw
switch goes into the river dove
thank you very much do we have any
questions yes councilman
you mentioned that you've had a serious
flooding incident in the last year
did this flood any other properties uh
in the in the area
at all please any properties did you say
any properties well you've seen
photographs on the
on the screen what you didn't see is
that runoff was going into
the garden of one of the houses opposite
the existing pro
the latest development okay and are you
aware that you mentioned all about the
the sewage was the sewage
also going you know going into the
property as a result of that flood the
garden
the sewage situation has been ongoing
for a number of years
um and it has obviously been made worse
by the fact that we have had
had infilling development in the village
we've had lots of discussions with
anglian water
who are the main people who maintain
their village they
they contend that the sewage system is
adequate
however the search system was put in a
number of decades ago
when the village was a lot smaller than
it is today
we have a planning permission for a
further 15 houses
in the village which you saw on the
screen there which obviously is going to
add an
additional load to the one that we're
already looking at
thank you very much thank you thank you
any other questions
yes counselor morley
you mentioned about the services within
the village
um you didn't say anything about health
care provision or school
provision is there any in the village
and given the
two already identified
sites in the emerging joint local plan
what effect do you think the
additionality
of these properties is going to have on
the ability of the village to sustain
those amenities thank you
we certainly do not have either a school
nor
medical facilities within the village
the medical
uh requirement of villages is catered by
metal shim or bacton
bacton has a very good
medical center and so i believed as
mendelssohn
schools definitely no schools the
nearest one is gizlingham
which is full backton i'm talking about
primary schools now
uh as full also so the school problem
is major a major problem in our area
we've had situations where um siblings
cannot even attend the same school
thank you okay we
um we'll move on we've invited the uh
representatives of westhalt parish
council to come today but i don't
believe anyone
is here is that correct no okay so
next we'll move on uh to an objector mr
andrew cardi
mr carter you have three minutes to
address the committee
uh over to you
thank you thank you chair um there are a
large number of valid reasons to a
director report primarily
in my opinion and the shared opinion the
report is inconsistent
and flawed making it an unsafe basis to
make a judgment
specifically the report attempts to
establish the road outside the site is
not dangerous
which is wrong factually incorrect and
at best misleading
the data on the site used the the data
on the site used by the offer is out of
date
up to a year old there have been at
least four accidents
that we know of at the proposed site
entrance
at the proposed site including one
involving a car and a horse which was
within recent months
the recent speed camera data available
at the time the report shows vehicles
approaching the
proposed sites at seven up to 76
miles per hour and with many in excess
of 50 miles per hour in both directions
this would not be safe on the a140 on a
straight stretch
so how can it be deemed safe in a 30
mile per hour zone
on a blind bend on a blind corner those
images do not do justice to the fact
that it's a blind
bend in a blind corner because that
google camera
is above the height of a car someone
driving the car will not see that
they will be on a blind bend on a blind
corner
let me ask you if an accident were to
occur here how
and these have been raised these issues
have been raised
how how would you justify your decision
today
if questions were raised about why this
was put in such a
dangerous location furthermore the local
policies mentioned in the report all
clearly
and explicitly state that the
application should be rejected
however the report author disregards
them by making subjective age-based
judgments on when the local policy
policies should be overwritten by the
mppf despite the mppf mentioned in the
current contrary in paragraph
213 where existing policies should not
be considered out of date simply because
they are adopted or made prior to the
publication of this framework
this is com to me this is confused in
illogical reasoning and it calls into
question the
quality of this report it's also key to
consider that this development
is not fit for the future the climate
change committee is a statutory body
which advises the government and it
clearly states in their 2019 report
that local authorities should prioritize
locating housing in
areas which minimizes extra traffic it
is clear the residents of this site will
require the use of
cars to access basic amenities for
example the report incorrectly mentions
the local shop as an immunity even
though it's rarely open
and it doesn't stop the basics that
would negate regular car travel
it also fails to mention the transport
as we've mentioned is not sufficient
to negate car travel again
this clearly demonstrates that the site
fails the recommendations of the report
and will introduce more car traffic and
co2 into the environment
councillor hicks how will this help you
deliver your manifesto
pledge to protect and enhance the
environment
due to the lack of immunity this site
you're you have to have the last
sentence after this okay
the site also has the potential for
social isolation it has many of the
hallmarks that are known to cause social
isolation
including lack of transportation and a
lack of opportunity
uh employment opportunity thank you
thank you very much
okay um any questions for the objective
no okay thank you very much thank you
we now move on uh to the agent philip
kobold
you have three minutes to address the
committee uh over to you
thank you chairman this development was
the subject of positive
pre-amplification discussions with
planning officers
although the site is outside of the
current settlement boundary for
finningham
your office has acknowledged that the
council's current core strategy and
local plan policies
are out of date because they do not
reflect the objectives of the nppf
and also that the council's decision to
grant planning permission
on the adjacent land demonstrated that
it considered finningham to be a
suitable
and sustainable location for housing
growth this is further illustrated by
the fact that the emerging local
plan proposes two housing allocations in
the village
one in in wickham road which already
benefits from planning permission
and a second in gizzlingen road
gizzlingham road does not have a footway
and therefore future residents of any
housing there would have to walk in the
road
to get to the village centre this site
provides a better solution for housing
growth
as there is a footway along west thorpe
road leading back to the centre of the
village the public house
and the bus stops at the crossroads this
site is there
therefore has far better connectivity
than the land which is allocated in
gizlingham road
it is also adjacent and opposite
existing houses
and so links well with the street scene
in response to the various objections
and concerns firstly the flooding in the
highway as you've heard that problem
is an historic highway issue for suffolk
county council
to resolve it has not been caused by the
adjacent development
and it will not be worsened by the
proposed development as surface water
will have to be dealt with by a sud
system
which requires surface water drainage to
be dealt with within the site boundary
secondly regarding the impact of the
development on the listed building on
the opposite side of the road
as you've heard this is an outline
application so matters relating to the
scale layout and appearance of dwellings
along the site frontage
are details which can all be resolved at
the reserve matters stage
it's also been suggested that the
application is applied to avoid
affordable housing
as you've heard this is not the case the
site and the adjacent site
currently being developed are in
different land ownerships the applicant
does not own this site
the owner of this site does not own the
adjoining land and never has
an application was not made for both
sites at the same time
because the land was not available at
that point and as you've heard we've
provided the planning officer
with appropriate evidence of land title
ownership and we understand that he's
satisfied on these details
parish council alleges there are issues
with foul water but if there is a
current angle
if the current anglery water system is
causing problems then there's a matter
for the utility operator themselves to
resolve
as part of the the pre-application due
diligence carried out by the developer
the anglian water confirmed that the
connection was available
parish council suggesting that their
village is not sustainable does not
accord with the district council's
proposals to allocate further land for
development in the local plan
although the village has limited
amenities and a limited bus service
clearly it was considered suitable and
sustainable otherwise those
three minutes is up so could i have the
final sentence please
different sites um are they related in
any way
the the people not as far as i'm aware
i think all that's happened is that one
owner has seen the land next to his land
being developed
he's liked what's being built on there
and then at the later stages approached
the developer
to see if he would be interested in
purchasing that site
okay thank you any other questions nope
okay so we'll move on to the ward member
over to you
uh thank you chair um we're always told
to
consider each application on its own
merits
so i'd like to take a few minutes of
members time to set out
the reasons why this application should
be refused
finningham's a lovely village it's rural
a medium-sized village of over 200 homes
and with the settlement patterns spread
out over quite a few miles of
rural roads and despite its many charms
what finningham lacks
are the services that other communities
enjoy
as we've heard there's no health center
the old primary school is closed
and is now private dwelling there is no
shop
though an enterprising smallholder does
sell a few items from her home
there is a pub the white horse which has
been open
intermittently over the last few years
there's a parish church
but no village hall so overall we don't
have the sort of facilities that would
make finningham
a sustainable location residents are
inevitably dependent on their cars
to access services which are found in
places like backton
or gizmo there is a vestigial
bus service which is actually a minibus
uh going back
back and forward to stow market and then
the once a weekly bus
through from i to berry edmonds
but that's not enough to provide a
realistic transport alternative to reach
a range of local services so i'm arguing
that this site is not a sustainable
location
as per paragraphs 102 to 104 of the
nppf now the office of report
argues that the principle of development
is clearly has
already established here because the
adjacent site for six
homes has gained permission and if that
is pretty much built out
however this permission was gained
during the period
when the council did not have a
five-year land supply we are now in a
very different situation
the five-year land supply is back we
have a joint local plan
which has been submitted and the
examination is beginning later this
month
now that plan does allocate two sites
for development in the village
one of which green farmers gain
permission and work is due to start
sometimes this year
and then there's another site of
gizzlingen road that's been mentioned
so the village will experience a certain
amount of development despite
the lack of facilities this site was put
forward in a call for sites but
has not made it into the jlp and the jlp
is the direction of travel
and so i don't agree that this site
should be approved just because
the adjacent site was previously
this application needs to be dealt with
on its own merits
now i just want to compare this site
with two other applications nearby
that was in dc 210998
which was in backton very very similar
to this application eight homes
a countryside location on the edge of
backton and close to a heritage asset
and that was refused on the 16th of
april this year
and not by committee this is by an
officer
reasons for refusal contrary to the
development plan policies fc1 and fc 1.1
and the mppf an unsustainable location
there was an impact on the character of
the countryside harm to a heritage asset
and not enough information on access
almost precisely the circumstances we
have for this application
and then dc 1905318
in west thorpe this was refused
basically a year ago this proposal would
not provide a suitable location for
housing respect to satisfactory
access to services and facilities the
proposal is not considered to con
constitute a sustainable development
when assessed against the three tests of
sustainability as outlined within the
mppf
so we've got our own offices on two very
very similar
applications um resting the case for
refusal on the mppf
and our existing policies be they out of
date or not
so for consistent decision making we
need to
do the same here
for this case the road access will be
problematic
we don't have a plan of where exactly
the access will be
there have been accidents at this
location the flooding we've mentioned
to me this is a speculative application
it's the last
gasp of the developers before our jlp
comes in
and i ask members to refuse it thank you
thank you very much any questions at all
yes councilman
uh thank you chair um you mentioned that
this particular site
had been put forward um in the call for
sites
but hadn't made it into the land
allocations in the joint local plan
um maybe uh do you or or do our planning
officers
um know the reason why the planning
policy team decided it shouldn't be
taken further forward
thank you um i'm happy to answer that
chair that's okay
so on page 53 of your reports
um paragraph 3.19
this came through in the call for sites
as ss0807 it was discounted
based on its poor connectivity with the
rest of the village
thanks very much any other questions no
okay members so over thank you for that
over to us to discuss debate and come to
a conclusion
can i just kick off by just asking a
question because i just want some
clarity around something um
which is troubling me so we're being
asked to make a decision
uh today on an outline planning
permission around
a heritage asset but we have no
information
around the landscaping that could or may
not
may or may not protect that heritage
asset
so we're kind of saying well here's a
heritage asset here's a blank sheet of
paper
approve the blank sheet of paper then
the heritage action should be all right
to me it should be the other way around
so can we just explain
why there isn't anything there for us to
look at to be
conclusive that we are protecting the
heritage asset as much as possible
so in terms of the application it's made
in
outline so we have the secondary
application for reserve matters that
would
that would deal with that but i think as
well if you were in a position where
you were looking at the landscaping um
with all of the matters still reserved
you'd still be in a position where there
are elements of the application that you
might want to be aware of
in terms of appearance layout scale that
would also have an
impact on how effective that landscaping
might be
with regards to protecting the setting
of the listed building
i think having them all as a group
within a reserve matters
still gives the local planning authority
the degree of certainty it needs
in terms of the impact of the
application
on the setting of the listed building
you know in to that to that end we would
still have
the further submission of reserve
matters all we would be granting here is
the principle of development
with the details still to come
well i'll leave with others to discuss
and debate i'm
i find that difficult to but i'll listen
to others
counselor matthison thank you chair yeah
i
i must say reading reading the um
the reports and so on beforehand
i did find the the parish and
and the world members arguments about
sustainability
rather more convincing um and
i think the what
to pity we started to get into the
debate
uh in discussing um the sustainability
and the weights of policies and so on
uh which i i was keeping back from and
until we reached the debate and
it it seems to me that we've got we've
got our
our old policies cs1 and cs2 which have
limited
weight and they are saying no refuse
and we've got the we've got the joint
local plan which has
limited but increasing at the moment
weight
which has also said no actually
we've got the settlement boundary and
this doesn't fit within it
and we've got the um we've got the
substantia that sorry the less than
substantial harm
um and the which inevitably
there must be some of although the
chairs express the doubt as to
um the degree of that because the
landscaping
isn't isn't with us so we've got those
several
reasons or policies each of which are
individually of
limited weight and and then we finally
got
the the very questionable sustainability
of this
village and and if you look at the
the assessment under the three legs of
sustainability
um really the the the economic the
social
and the environmental benefits of this
application
really are very very thin each of them
none of them has got real substance to
them
so the question the question we have to
decide
is whether all those
limited reasons limited weights combined
are should be out out um outweighed by
the precedent that was set at a time
when we were under pressure
because we had not got a five-year land
supply and
really i i would challenge the
the argument that the the
the the out-of-date policies
um are as significant
uh uh in in determining what happens
as as are the the the lack of a
five-year land supply was three years
ago
and and i you know i don't really
want to accept that those two the the
the tilted balance
is as significant as the lack of
five-year land supply
somehow we've got actually we've got to
actually challenge
that argument can we just on that point
just actually because i mean it's a
i think it's you've hit this is one of
the cruxes of the application
and i just would like to get a view on
what would happen at appeal
based on what you've just said so john
could you come in and just give us a
view
on certain we need to hear let's just
hear what the officer's view is if he
went to appeal on that basis
i'm actually really pleased to hear what
i'm hearing because
you're exactly where we are uh in the
debate
of what is the material consideration
that
should take precedence uh in this
particular case
and we have a range of material
considerations we have a future
limited weight local plan we have a past
local plan
of limited weight we have the nppf which
you can
interpret both ways the problem with the
nppf is that
when we dealt with it a few years ago
with the site next door
it essentially says the village is
sustainable and that's what
that is a precedent yes but it's not
because it was there as a development
it's because
of the considerations at the time at the
same time
we we have the fact that we have a joint
local plan coming forward that does have
a settlement boundary
um so on the other hand this is outside
the settlement boundary which you could
argue means
it's contrary to that future policy but
at this current time
that policy isn't engaged fully and we
are in the situation we have out of date
important policies and as an
evidence base we're about to allocate it
as a sustainable site for
development or at least immediately next
door to it
so if i'm standing in front of an
appeared inspector i have to argue the
difference between standing here
and standing there literally with the
meters of each other
one area sustainable the other area
isn't and i think we would find that
extremely
difficult to do so what i would perhaps
express to members
is that the debate maybe needs to look
at what is the actual harm
of this development or what is the
unknown harm that you wish to
understand further you know landscape
do you have sufficient information that
you think in principle that this site
wouldn't be intrusive
to the countryside heritage you have
mentioned
do you have sufficient information to
understand that relationship that you
feel that reserve matters can resolve
or is it just too uncertain at this
point in time
it perhaps is those issues that would
give you
an analysis that you need can i just
follow up can i just follow is that all
right
so i agree 100 so the sustainability
question is an issue because of what's
happened next door i get all that
but uh can you just elaborate on the
intrusiveness
of this site on the countryside uh
bearing in mind the lack of a landscape
plan because i mean it is is
i mean to me that is a problem it's a
big problem so how can i deal with that
can i send it to back that we
if we didn't if the others and obviously
we're still very early in the position
but if there was a view that that was a
major consideration
could we refuse it and say we would want
a full application to go to committee
not just an outline to actually get all
the detail was that just
not in our remit
the other variable here is this is up to
eight
which makes it interesting because
ultimately reserve matters may only come
in for six that
hardly ever happened we know but
ultimately
these could be eight very small
properties where landscaping is a
dominant factor
and therefore does mitigate the
potential harm
or impact of the development um
this is the problem this is why i do
personally hate outlines
it is that leaf of faith that
we are looking at in terms of what
officers are saying is we think it's a
possibility
that you could have a successful scheme
on here that does not harm
the listed building that does not have
an intrusive impact on the landscape
because we feel the details are possible
that can be achieved there will be a
design solution somewhere
however if members are not convinced of
the same
that is for you to debate yeah so can i
just sorry sorry to hog the mic but if
that
is the view of members can we say can
you refuse an application on the basis
that you want to see
a full planning permission to be able to
make that judgment
you can refuse on the basis that i would
suggest that you say
it fails to demonstrate your
satisfaction
that you have sufficient information um
to consider the principle of development
okay thank you
sorry to hold the mic i just want to get
to the bottom of my landscape issues
council madison if you want to come back
yeah i i think the
i think what i would what i would argue
based on most of the paper jesus has
just been saying
is you know the actual harm and what is
the change from three years ago
i think the answer is we're three years
wiser about how very serious climate
change
uh is going to be and the
this this is quite clearly
going to be if it's developed a car
dependent
development and we should not be i
suspect that mppf might have actually
changed in the last three years
on that point of of climate change as
well
uh and the the chairs made some you know
reasonable additional point about the
impact on the countryside
um so you know i i really i really
you know it is not sustainable location
to develop
we shouldn't take what we what we were
forced to do
three years ago as as any kind of
precedent for what we should do today
okay next up is counselor mansell
thank you chair um i'm going to i i'm
i completely agree with everything
council matheson has said
so i'm not going to hop on about
sustainability but and
and i think that uh mr payment g might
have taken some of the words
out of my mouth because i i do think
that we have no evidence that the um
development on this site um can be done
in such a way
to minimize what our heritage officers
have said is a medium
level of less than substantial harm
often we're talking about
low levels here we have a medium level
of less than substantial harm
we know nothing about how the
landscaping is going to
deal with the situation of it being
opposite this listed building
from the photographs and i i i am
familiar
with that particular road it's it looks
as if that um house is on a
on a curved bit of road on the brow of a
hill
anything on that raised bank opposite it
is surely going to affect the setting of
that listed building
we also have the unknown of where the
access is going to be
on this winding curving um
road on an incline near the perceived
brow of a hill
um we don't know where the access is
going to be we've heard that there are
already issues on that road
and okay there's been four accidents i
don't know what the death rate was or
anything and we know
that um we have to have several deaths
before anything's ever done about road
safety
um so i am in complete agreement with
the ward member that this is a
speculative
uh application um
and i actually think that our planning
policy officers
who've already assessed the site and
decided that it wasn't connected to the
village and here we have the planning
offices saying that it has a good
relationship
but i really do think that we have not
got sufficient information
to determine whether there are going to
be any issues with the
heritage or the highways on this
particular application
thank you very much uh councillor muller
and cancer cast
thank you chair yes i've listened with
interest to the various comments on this
one
i must say i'm not happy with this
particular application at all and i must
admit the comments made by mr peyton g i
do agree with i think perhaps we could
refuse this one
initially i would like to see a full
planning application for this
i agree with what the chair said about
the uh
the listed building it mentions in the
papers
about a green buffer we have a green
verge there at the moment you know
would we say just have a green version
would there be hedgerow planted etcetera
there's so many
unknowns with this particular
application as it stands at this moment
so i do not feel like i support it in
its present form
thank you casa casten
thank you um yeah i think i'm um
in agreement with councillor muller on
that one
this um this sustainability issue
for me is is not a great one but the um
the fact that there's a site next door
that is considered sustainable
i think is um is very different it was a
very different time and it was a very
different landscape when we were
operating the tilted balance
and things have changed now with the the
higher land supply
the um but the main thing for me here is
um
like you say i understand that not
everything has to be in an outline
planning permission
but we usually have a fairly good idea
of how it's going to work
in an outline planning permission this i
think
just tells us where it is and not
a huge amount else um and it's very hard
to um
once that outline plan and permission
has been agreed
it's there's it's a lot harder to stop
at uh
reserve matters if it really just
doesn't work but um
this grade two um listed building here
um a medium um
risk so um if it was a high risk i don't
think we'd
even consider this so i think medium
risk has to be um
taken as quite quite a large risk
for a grade two listed building i'd like
to see a layout
that really showed us how that would
look
um i can't really see how it can be done
now without
impacting that at least a medium
risk amount so um
yeah i i don't particularly like this
application i think this is definitely
not a um
not a clear one to um
approve it's whether it would get if we
refuse it whether it would come back to
us
on um appeal i'm
i think there's enough reason there that
it wouldn't come back to us
on appeal but i would welcome looking at
a
a more detailed um um application
as well on that thank you thank you
yes you want to come in yep
apologies just two small minor matters
just to
ensure for the purposes of the record um
in terms of the heritage officer's
response
the median point is about impact the
harm
of its significance is identified as low
towards medium
i just want to clarify that for the
record to make sure we're not getting
confused
ultimately in terms of the official uh
point of that
the less than substantial harm is the
rating if you like that that you take
from the mppf
that's one point there's been a lot of
mention about accidents
um i don't know if this helps members
but just briefly
i did have a quick look on the crash map
which is the official recording of
accidents from slight minor
and fatal there is no recording of
accidents along this
road for the last 22 years so that's up
to 2020.
there is three accidents recorded at the
junction
to i've forgotten what the name of the
junction is sorry the
uh west fork road and be
the washroom road junction where the
white where the pub is
there's three there uh at various times
through that 22 years
um that's not to say there isn't
accidents along this road it's just a
case of what is recorded as evidence
when it comes down to having a debate
about that issue
thank you councilman back to you
uh well having listened to some of my
fellow
members on the committee i thought maybe
i would
propose refusal on the grounds of
we don't have sufficient information to
know whether there will be a heritage
problem or a highways problem
as mentioned by um mr payment g that
that
we could have that as a reason for
refusal is that we don't have sufficient
information about
this application in order to make a
judgment on those
issues is that correct can i just try
just check so i mean one thing
we're always asked to consider a
committee is um does the public
uh benefit uh outweigh any harm and i
i don't think we can make that judgment
based on what's before us
that's my i mean that's my take on it uh
yeah councilwool boys you were next
uh yes i i agree with councillor
lancel and i probably second that i
would like to
put in another point really and it's
about the principle
of development and there's mr pavement
in the case
oh sorry i forget it's on this and
uh i apologize right um i agree
completely without council manchester
has been said and uh
would like to support a proposal um
i think my my uh
questions really arise around whether
the principle of development has really
been
established and i take on board mr
payment g's
uh explanations and the case officers
explanation
i've read through pages 51-53
several times and i've found it quite
contradictory
paragraph 317 for example says policy h7
of the local plan seeks to restrict
housing development in the countryside
in the interests of protecting its
existing character
and appearance which i think fits this
situation
very well over paragraph 3.8
the proposal site is located in the
countryside and therefore
does not accord with policies cs1 cs2
and h7
i i assume that's a typo but i'm not
certain um for me the
when harris talks about residential
development
will inevitably transform the rural
character of the land that positively
contributes to the setting
and significance of a listed building
we've looked at slides 10 and 11 which
shows the approach into
fining them and and the impact
of the adjacent development
[Music]
subjectively i think the listed building
is still in a rural location
[Music]
further development would actually sort
of
envelope it in a an urban
more of an urban townscape
and i think we we neglect these heritage
assets they're incredibly important
to our rural
um tourism this the the whole
environment which mit suffolk is
regarded as so i think we
sh the weight we attach to that and how
we protect them
is really important um
sustainability has been
uh phillyman's got limited bus service
um and i think though it is outside
perhaps what we consider the the sow
the sewage situation regard to anglian
water we've sort of not
really addressed it i think it is of
concern
we talked about precedence we've seen
this matter arise
in the development in finland where
sewage was an incredible problem and it
did
overshadow further development and um
as far as i know it's still not being
resolved satisfactory by anglia water
so the arguments about whether we have
enough information
to support this i think i don't think we
do
and i think in particular the the
principle of development
i think that needs to be for me much
clearer
i don't feel it's been established
um as solidly
as we say while the emergent joint local
plan is not supportive of the
development
and the fact that the development on the
immediate adjacent side was considered
to be acceptable
that is in a very different time and
it's a different space
and we now have a five-year
housing uh supply which i should imagine
was a lever
with in respect to the previous
development
thank you uh can i just ask uh john
pemdry just to
uh pick up all the different points that
everyone's made we've been around a
couple of times i think we've got to be
careful
that we that if we're going to refuse
this we refuse it on grounds that don't
shoot ourselves in the foot if it goes
to appeal as well and and i think the
question around sustainability with the
site next door
is going to be the big discussion point
as to as to whether that is valid or not
valid when we have a sustainable
location being built out next door
but john can i hand over to you just to
summarize
you've heard it proposed by council
mansell seconded by council of war boys
for
the reasons of refusal could i ask you
just to
give your thoughts and maybe some
summary on that
i'm not sure this is close enough you
can hear me all right
um i've been typing away while
everybody's been talking so i'll be
honest with you i've been constructing
something that
i think covers bits and pieces that
people have been talking about so
bear with me if i get through this to
sort of give you something
to consider um the first issue really
that comes out
most strongly here is the heritage asset
so
what you're suggesting to me is that
a low to medium level uh of less than
substantial harm
to the setting of the hill house which
is listed building has been identified
and the proposal fails to have
sufficient information to demonstrate no
harm
the application also fails to
demonstrate the public benefits of the
development
would outweigh this identified harm in
terms of the requirement of the mppf
especially
paragraph 196 and therefore you are
finding it potentially contrary to both
the nppf
and your policies cs05 which is your
core strategy
and your safe local plan policy hb1
that ties up the heritage point
the second reason you may want to
consider further
listening to what uh council walkways
was just saying
um you're thinking about the settlement
boundary and i i agree we are into this
position where
what are the different circumstances
here compared to a couple of years ago
and the tests that were considered back
then
um one thing that is changed
which does make a difference is actually
the harm to the list of building
um within the nppf if you
identify a harm to the list of building
you can actually
within paragraph 11 suggests that the
tilted balance therefore does not engage
because of the heritage asset so
a suggestion therefore might be that
you're talking about sustainability in
the settlement boundary specifically
you are effectively saying that this
location is both
outside the settlement boundary now it
is not an allocated site
and it will continue to be located
outside the settlement boundary
under be it limited weight the proposed
joint local plan
and on this basis the application is not
held to be in a compliance with your
development plan policies cs1 cs2
h7 um fc 1.1
and they are held to while they are not
held to be out of date
and do not engage the tilted balance
given the harm to the listed building
and provisions of the mppf paragraph 11.
so that is a way to engage them
more fully in this particular site
because you are identified
the harm to the listed building
being very careful about saying that
would that help
uh councillor mansell your view
um yeah i i i i'm happy with that thank
you and councilwood
i'm happy with boys i think it implies
further reading but
yeah yes okay anyone else wish to just
talk about this or discuss it before we
go to a vote
okay get cancer field
yes just agree with that last exchange
that
um the mppf clearly allows you to build
outside settlement boundaries in the
country as long as the
places you're building are not isolated
and this would
not be isolated but the comments
concerning the listed building do
do seem to justify not building in this
particular spot outside of the
settlement boundary so that does seem to
make the decision much more secure to me
thank you very much well on that basis
uh we'll go to the
uh robert carmichael governor's office
to take a vote
thank you chair as with the previous one
if you're happy to i can do it
by um the reasons as read out by the
area planning manager
if members are happy with that
no you said it to me afterwards john
that's fine so as long as all members
are
clear on that point and share your
accepting of that
yeah so it's on the reasons that we've
just heard read out by john pate mcgee
and that's the
on the basis that we're going to vote
for refusal
thank you chair i will now start the
vote so if members could please go
to the modern.gov app and go to the plus
sign in the top right hand corner on
today's agenda
then go to the subsection on voting
attendance and then go to the light blue
color which shows the vote in
progress
that's a cast thank you very much i am
unable to
vote electronically
yep that's fine we just got to your
microphone isn't on because we've got
more than two so if i turn mine off
then
it's um for the proposal to refuse thank
you councillor
um so chair with that vote received i
can confirm there's a unanimous vote for
the proposal for refusal
okay thank you very much everyone um
[Applause]
sorry on the wrong side of the page okay
so um do uh last question
do we have any uh site inspection
request that needs to be reported to the
committee
no chair no okay thank you very much
well i formally closed the meeting at 12
17.
thank you everyone for your time this
morning